[Music]
on today's show you better not pout or
cry because we're talking about
parenting and santa claus and elf on the
freaking shelf we also talked to a
veteran who's really struggling we
talked to a woman who just lost her dad
and had a miscarriage and she's
wondering what to do next stay tuned
[Music]
what's up it's almost christmas here on
the dr john dolone's show and i hope
you're doing all right
and hope you're surviving with your
family or you're just sitting by a fire
doing nothing or you're shoveling snow
or you are still working you're one of
the millions and millions and millions
and millions of people who don't live
the fantasy and you're busting it today
however you're coming to us i'm so glad
you're with us um on this show we talk
about mental health relationships we
talk about everything anything
everything's going on in your life
we cross the gamut here and we got some
good stuff for you today james good to
see you kelly merry christmas it's good
to see everybody in there let's get
right to the calls today let's go to
john in flint michigan what's up brother
john how are we doing
i'm okay how are you doing john good man
good morning to you good morning to you
so what's going on hey by the way has it
started snowing like crazy there in in
flint
no we have no snow here no snow here wow
that's not what i expected
wow man
well so what's up man how can i help
so um my question is just dealing with
like everyday stressors right now um i
have a wife that is uh has a
neurological disorder and um i fall
behind some bills and
i'm just really extremely stressed out
and
kind of losing my mind and
really what to do because i mean i'm in
a situation where i'm the sole worker i
can't really reach out to anyone because
i don't have anyone to reach out to
and
it's just one of those situations where
i just don't know how to deal with the
stress anymore
tell me about your wife man
so um my wife has a very difficult past
path of
um
the emotional and physical
abuse most of her life
um and she'll she has multiple different
uh mental disorders but last year she
was diagnosed with um
a neurological disorder that causes her
to essentially lose control of her
entire body where
it realizes she wants to be able to
speak she won't be able to talk
what's it called
speak talk walk do anything
um and so that's been an upwards battle
since
earlier this year um when i got
diagnosed what's the diagnosis what's
the official diagnosis um it's called um
vestibular migraines is what it's called
um
it's a misleading name because it
actually doesn't deal with migraines it
deals with
blockages within the brain which doesn't
send the signals to where they need to
go is it like inflammatory of of the
brain
that's yeah that's yeah exactly okay um
man so do you got little ones
yes we do we have two little ones three
and seven three and seven man
number one i'm sorry dude that sucks
that's hard
that's hard man it's been a long i it
was it was hard before this diagnosis
wasn't it
yeah yeah
um how did you meet her
um me and my wife actually met um at a
bar on veterans day when me and a couple
of my buddies were out celebrating
veteran days
man so are you veteran
yes i am where'd you serve
i was in the marine corps for six years
six years man
uh stateside or deployed
spacex very cool man well thank you for
your service my brother appreciate you
um tell me about your experience in the
marines
um i mean i loved it i mean i was
actually planning on going back once i
got done with law school and passed the
bar but that just never happened because
life changes but um are you in law
school experience okay are you in law
school now
no i've already graduated law school but
i haven't passed my state bar uh okay um
so did you fail the first time out
yep okay
not that you had anything going on or
anything like that
all right right
wow
man
you like the marine corps huh
yeah no i mean it's it's a it's a life
it's lifestyle i mean it's it's
something that will forever change you
so you want to go back and do jag
with them yeah that's what the original
plan was but i mean now i mean
i'm right now i work in the mortgage
business i underwrite loans okay and
stuff like that so i mean as much as i
i'm not as young as i once was so i just
there's no funny going back anymore
so you're done done though
yeah it's more of the uh fantasy it's
cool to work out and watch jocko videos
it's pretty cool right
essentially yeah um
man
tell me about your financial situation
so
um back in september i was actually let
go of my previous job
because they weren't willing to work
with me to deal with
taking my life to and from doctor's
appointments and
taking my kids to and from school
so that was actually a back and forth
deal with them actually terminating me
the day that i actually told them hey
federal states this and you need to
give me accommodations
well three hours after i send that email
they terminated me
so i was out of a job for
over a month okay
so everything i had saved up
i used towards the bills to push them
out as far as i could
and even still that put me probably
about three grand in the hole okay and
so and then this job you have now are
you making decent money to pay bills and
get caught back up
so i
it covers the bills but it really
doesn't leave much room for savings
until i get out of training and start
actually producing
money or pretty soon again there you go
assistance is a new job
yeah okay why flint michigan why y'all
living in michigan
um well we we both grew up here we i
mean we don't live necessarily in flint
we live outside of flint but um but you
got nobody there no friends no family
we have family but it's not really like
a support system right like they're not
a very good support system so so why do
y'all live there
well we want to move out but like right
now we just can't afford it we just
don't have the ability to do so okay
um
man how honest can i be with you
it's it's early in the morning and i
don't want to come after you early in
the morning but honestly i i i i'm a
very important person i take things very
bluntly so
so
i want you to fully grasp what you've
experienced over the last six months or
a
year
um probably the last two to five years
and probably even further back how old
are your kids one more question how
would your kids
seven and three seven three
okay
so man you have experienced one
trauma after another after another
marine corps is bonding it's connecting
and it's hard on your body in your mind
you agreed
i agree okay
um you see some stuff and you
experienced some stuff agreed
i agree okay
then you get out you lose your community
you lose your mission your purpose your
your your check in and check out which
some people love that it's i hear often
when i work with veterans it's really
disorienting because you just had
somebody telling you when and what for
so long and in such micro units of a day
um that it's disorienting is that your
experience
um
not really because i was i mean i was
able to transition pretty quickly i mean
it wasn't really hard for me to
transition because i was still i was
still in school while i was in the core
so the transition was very simple for me
who who became your friends after you
got out your gang your buddies
essentially people within law school and
other marines i don't hang out with law
students man
you know that
um you know i was a dean of students at
a law school for a while
for years and that's a whole other
adventure right
so then you go to law school
and i studied law student mental health
that's another trauma a big one and a
slow drip one that slowly drowns you
agreed
i definitely agree okay
then you're you're with a you're married
to somebody who has experienced some
significant relational trauma and that's
just heart
agreed
yep then her body continues to go to war
with her until it finally can push it
all the way to get that snowball all the
way on top of the hill and pushes it
down and her body says we're out agreed
yep and by the way you got two little
ones one that's old enough to get in
everything and one that still needs
diapers
and
she's actually fully penetrated so no
diapers all right well i'm giving the
last two years right over the last two
years right then you
are working a job that you hate and you
get fired
like on trying to help your family
getting fired from a job's a big trauma
and then
and then you fail the bar and then and
then and then
and so i want you to just pause for a
second in the middle of this and i know
you felt it and it's all over the place
i want you to hear me
tell you you've been through hell
agreed
i agree have you taken a big deep breath
and dropped your shoulders and just said
crap
every day
[Laughter]
okay
so here's what happens when
people find themselves in this situation
their brain
begins over time loved ones community
that your path out which was law school
your plan which is law school back to
jack and then law school let's do
private practice and now i'm
underwriting loans and i don't even like
that the mortgage industry is
ridiculous it's a everything's a mess
and then this and then this and then oh
my gosh i get fired and it's not even
fair and and and
what your brain starts to do is look at
every potential out whether it's
relational whether it's occupational
whether it is um connection with family
whatever it is as dead end dead end dead
end dead end and the word that you feel
right now is absolutely trapped fair
yep you got nowhere to go
and so what i want to i want to
challenge you
is when you say i got nobody i'm going
to call bull crap on that
when you say we just we just don't can't
leave here we're just stuck here i'm
going to call bull crap on that
when you say i just i just gotta i just
have to
what i wanna do is push on that
because you got to you're too smart
you've got too many skills and you've
been through too much and you're too
much of an asset to the community that
my kids are growing up in
so i want you to hear me say it's just a
fellow dad forget all the tv and all the
radios
like i need you in my community
you know too much you're too valuable to
me
to underwrite loans and some crappy job
that you don't even like
fair
yeah okay
so what i need you to do is decide
i'm gonna find a job it's gonna pay us
to move the last three jobs i've taken
they've paid me to move
you can have that too
they they help underwrite my transition
from wherever to wherever you need to
get to texas where it's warm or come
here to nashville or it's just bonkers
you can move if your family is not safe
you got to decide i'm going to make it a
mission to get people in my life
get people in my life around me
where i can have community because i
can't do life without it whether that's
a local church whether that's friends
whether it's getting together a marine
group whatever that is
you've reached a point where you have to
have recon and you've got to make it an
a1 priority
fair
yeah when's the last time you went and
worked out took care of your body and
your mind did something for you
a couple months ago
okay
so when we feel trapped we just get that
that that spiral gets tighter and
tighter and tighter and then the only
thing that works man is a 12-pack and
netflix or some game of some sort or
video whatever the thing is
i'm telling you this stuff and you know
it tell me where you're stuck my brother
i just i just don't know where to go i
mean i've
i've reached out to churches i've done
therapy i've done
like
everyone i would normally reach out to
is just dealing with so much [ __ ] right
now that like i i'm not adding on to it
it's not something that i do
okay um
so i just i just drop it in
john you're not a burden
you're not a burden man
and i get feeling like you're at the end
you're doing a lot of reaching out
but i'd love to see you here's what i
want you to do i want you to do this
i want you to take out a piece of paper
and do this off air and then here's what
i'm going to do i'm going to have you
back on this show because i want to walk
through this with you over the next five
six months is that fair will you do that
with me
yeah okay
i want you to
sit down today alone by yourself i want
you to take an hour
i want you to write down all the
stressors in your life every single one
of them start to finish
from
brokenhearted about my wife to wife's
illness to kids if your kids got
learning to say whatever the thing is
money stress reach out to this person
denied counseling sucks i want you to
write down every stressor you have
and i want you to get it at arm's length
out of your head and onto a piece of
paper so that it becomes a series of
challenges to work through
not something that is debilitating and
taking over your body
will you do that
yeah okay i want you to do that and then
kelly's gonna reach back out to you and
we're gonna do this again in a few weeks
and in a few weeks you're gonna i want
you to read me the list
of these challenges
and i want you to pick three or four of
the biggest ones and begin to
don't don't go call somebody
you are good
i want you to create a plan that's going
to start with i need to start exercising
and taking care of my body
i need to quit drinking i need to quit
and i'm just picking that up i'm just
making that up i don't even know if you
drink or not do you
no okay so i'm just picking some
whatever the thing is
i'm gonna start by honoring my body
period number two i'm gonna start by
playing with my key just doing something
silly like playing with my kids
number three i'm gonna start applying
for jobs in other states
what's the worst that can happen they
can tell us no great i'm on to the next
i'm going to sign up for the bar
and i am going to start making some hard
phone calls to people because i'm not a
burden
and i'm going to need some babysitting
over the next six months because i got
to study and pass this test i need to
pass this test i'm not giving up on this
i want you to begin to come up with a
plan and then in a few weeks we're going
to circle back and i'm going to walk
alongside you is that fair and if you
start these things and i want you to
come at me hard there's bullcrap doing
that call this call this nothing nothing
nothing and we're going to walk through
every bit of it and your journey is
going to help millions of people you in
yeah all right
so today your homework assignment for
today is write all your stressors down
get them all lined up
and begin with the top three to five and
we're gonna make a plan and you're gonna
be uncomfortable and it's gonna be weird
and you're gonna have to keep thinking
i'm not a burden i'm not a burden and i
start with me and then i'm with my kids
and then we're going from there
okay
john i need you in my community and i
want you in my community you're just
feeling trapped and i need you to hear
me say you're not trapped and it starts
with taking little tiny steps little
steps
towards something new not accepting
i just can't i got no one i can't do a
thing i can't i don't accept that and i
don't want you to accept that either
because it's not true we'll be right
back with dr john on the show
all right let me clear up a common
misconception being tired all the time
is not normal and if you're always
exhausted take a good look at your
nightly sleep routine are you scrolling
the internet for hours or sharing a bed
with 17 animals in your spouse is your
mattress older than you listen the sleep
environment you create has so much to do
with how well you rest you've got to
protect it eliminate screens skip late
night snacks and have a bed you love
sleeping on like a dream cloud mattress
dream cloud is one of my favorite
mattresses because they're made of
premium sleep materials but they're half
the price of other premium brands they
also offer a 365 night trial and a
forever warranty to make sure you are a
hundred percent satisfied right now dr
john dolone's show listeners get 250
bucks off plus
399 dollars in sleep accessories like
pillows sheets you name it that's 649
in savings not to mention some deep deep
rest if your sleep routine needs
resetting check out dream cloud's
biggest offer ever
at
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
deloney all right we are back let's go
to ann in all four cities in iowa in the
quad cities what's up ann
hi
how are you
i'm freaking out right now i'm really
excited me too i am freaking out as well
why are you freaking out
um
just there's a lot going on but before i
get to that i will go straight to my
question i just want to say thank you so
much for all the work that you do and
are doing um it's been really meaningful
for me thank you that's meaningful for
me too for real because this hap the
whole thing happens in a vacuum we're
like locked in a studio here and james
doesn't let me listen to the show and so
um that means the world to me i'm
grateful for that yeah so
um
a couple of months ago my dad passed
away and so i'm still reading that i'm
sorry
how do you pass away
um so i'm not sure how much detail i
should get into but um essentially his
lungs gave out on him whatever you're
comfortable with
he had coveted and then it was a battle
and then he he just got tired
um
so i'm still working through that and
then um did you get to see him
i'm sorry i'm sorry if i keep
interrupting you i just i'm trying to
get a
a full picture did you get to see him or
did he have to yeah did he die by
himself
um so
early in the process when he was first
uh hospitalized you know we were able to
see him and and speak with him and he
was awake and then he ended up being
sedated and
that's how he passed um he was he was
alone he was out of state okay
i'm sorry
yeah it was tough it really was and
it still is right yeah yeah it is it is
all right so then the next
yeah so then as i was walking through
that um i unexpectedly found out that i
was pregnant
and was processing that um and then
within a time frame of about four days i
found out i was pregnant found out my
numbers were not where they should be
and
ended up being an ectopic pregnancy and
so i miscarried
um and that was kind of traumatic but it
was it required surgery and things
um not kind of
it was tragic yeah it sucked suck suck
suck
go in knowing that's the that the end
result there right
yes did you lose your flipping two
yes i lost one of my fallopian tubes
okay
so you lost an organ in the deal
yes i did
um so was this pregnancy exciting was
this pregnancy scary or are you all by
yourself you got other kids like give me
the context for the pregnancy yeah so it
was exciting unexpected but exciting um
i do have two other children one is four
and one is almost two
um and we were not planning on having
any more children so we were kind of
blindsided by it but once we found out
we were excited yeah yeah
um
did you just did you land on a name
no we we didn't even get that far the
furthest we get was me
upset because we were gonna have to buy
a van and i really don't want a van
you would have been an awesome van mom
ann
yeah and with the fans that have been
awesome yeah right that would have been
a great bumper sticker exactly
oh man oh yes but my question is um
i like i didn't want to have another
child but after having gone through all
of this i kind of want to have another
child
and
i'm thinking is that selfish is that
something that i shouldn't even be
thinking of because i've gone through so
much within the past couple of months
um but that's kind of where i'm at yeah
so
first and foremost
your feelings are your feelings and your
thoughts or your thoughts
they don't always tell us the truth but
they're real
does that make sense
it does so i want you whatever you're
feeling whatever you're thinking
whatever you desire now is all fine it's
all good
and you have been through
hell
because my guess is before your dad
passed it was hell and trying to love
somebody far away and whenever parents
pass away it's always a mixture of
ugh and heartbreak and all you know you
know what i mean you just went through
all that all that stuff
and then you got two little ones that
you're trying to parent and you got some
knucklehead husband you're trying to
probably parent to right all the stuff
and then
man
a corner of your heart got peeled back
and you didn't even know it was there
and all of a sudden it's
so every
everything you're feeling is great
and so hear me say if you want to have
another baby have another baby
if you found something new about
yourself that's one of life's great
adventures man go for it
and if you don't then don't th the
advice i got from when i was walking
through this very similar situation to
you ectopic pregnancy whole thing
um
the advice i got was from the a
counselor that i trust deeply with my
life and he's the guy who trained me on
crisis stuff um he said his
recommendation is to wait six months to
make any big life decisions after trauma
yeah
and so
um i know i know families who have
have one of my close friends lost
um a pregnancy at the very very very end
like month eight and a half or month
nine
and man they were pregnant soon after
great great
adventure for their family
um
and then others wait years
so everybody's different grief is
different for everybody
what's your husband think about it
he doesn't want to have another child
and we knew that you know before we we
got pregnant but
um he's willing to talk about it okay
here's here's the i'm not gonna tell you
how to do grief because grief is yours
okay
um i'll give you a couple of
recommendations but i will give you one
you've got to you've got to you've got
to is that fair
yeah okay
first one is don't try to get past this
stuff
fully experience it
yeah and keep doing your life
what do i mean by that
on sad days feel real real sad
let that sad just be a part of you for a
season
when you think about your dad and your
heart just feels like always a thousand
pounds feel that don't try to don't try
to
brush it off
and
make sure you go for a walk that evening
or you go do the class that you've
signed up for or you and your husband go
play a game whatever the thing is okay
so it's both and
and the two conv the two competing
wisdoms right now in our culture are
just suck it up and crush it and that
will go away or
you you do you and you just sit there
and let it wash over you for the next
five years and whenever you know what i
mean and what i want to say is there's a
third way it's both and okay
don't ignore that stuff because it will
weigh you down over time and don't let
it take over your life it's both and
and there will be days when it takes
over great get up the next day and have
a good day the next day
the second thing is this
you've got to got to got to let your
husband know what you're feeling
the thing that families even on
something like a miscarriage
is people grieve differently and they
start hiding their grief from one
another they start hiding their tomorrow
plans from one another and then all of a
sudden boom we are two inches apart and
2 000 miles away from our loved ones
sitting on the same couch right
yeah and so you've got to be honest with
him do you feel safe enough to be honest
with him
i do and you've been so supportive
awesome
oh that's so so so good
and then here's my other recommendation
this can be this can be um controversial
blah blah it's
whatever i don't care um
i would
give yourself the opportunity to name
this child
and to write this child letter
about how much you miss them
and you didn't get to get to meet them
but here's here's brothers and sisters
here's what life is is where we live
a just a conversation with
and it sounds counterintuitive like why
would i do that to myself why would i go
into that
what i'm hearing from you is your body's
already there your just heart and mind
isn't there
and so i would take that journey into
that conversation with a letter i'd
write your data letter have you done
that yet
yeah um
i started a journal
when he was sick and i just was was
keeping things that i wanted to share
with him there and
after he passed i continue to write to
him just in a different context good
good good good
have you told them the bad stuff too
not yet i haven't gotten there okay make
sure you do that because dads aren't
perfect
and your body will feel the gap between
a guy that you had some major
frustrations with probably not everybody
but probably am i am i onto something
no i mean he was great um but we were so
much alike that
we butted headphones there you go that's
right our two offensive linemen just
banging heads against each other so um
make sure you honor the tough stuff too
because both and because
he helped
he helped
mold into who you are both the good
stuff and the tough stuff the stuff that
your husband's like oh my gosh why that
you know some of that came from old man
right so honor all of it he reminds me
write him a letter about what you
learned from him what you didn't learn
from him what you should have learned
from him what you miss about him what
you are not going to miss about it's the
whole human experience okay yeah and
good for you for writing a journal what
a gift and i recommend anybody going
through that start that journal and
continue to write right
um
the the babies that we've lost in
miscarriage i've got their names
tattooed on my body
that's how big of a deal i think that is
okay
is to own it and to they're a part of us
and then we're gonna go on about what
tomorrow's gonna look like but that's
that's that's how me and my family
handled that um and then if you wanna
have another baby having a baby
have that conversation with your husband
and be all in is that cool
yeah i can do that
hear me say this there is no wrong way
to do this
other than keeping secrets
okay
and keeping secrets is the wrong thing
to do everything else
is a part of the the healing process
here
if you want another baby be honest with
them about having another baby and if it
doesn't end up happening it doesn't end
up happening um but good for you
so
can i just tell you
brother to sister i'm sorry my heart's
broken for you
thank you
and it doesn't bring anybody back this
makes anything better but i want you
know you're not alone and that that
grief is hard i'm sorry
thanks for being with
us well thank you um
for
walking through it with me um i i don't
feel alone um awesome and i think that's
part of the reason that you know i've
started to open up and share some of my
story with others because
i don't feel alone but i know that
others might you know who are work
walking through a similar situation so
yeah
yeah
and in the process of wanting to help
other people don't forget to start with
you
your oxygen mask goes on first
you deserve a night of sleep you need to
take care of your body you need to take
care of your relationships and then
you're
strong enough well enough to love and
walk alongside other people as they
their dark days descend on them and we
all have them i'm grateful for your
heart grateful for you yeah you're not
crazy
grief's uh you're in tough season tough
season tough season but uh man it's been
an honor talking with you we'll be right
back on the dr john de lima show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndalone.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right we are back let's go to uh we
were coming from quad cities and now
we're just going to twin cities
minnesota let's go to emily what's going
on emily
i'm good dr don how are you i am
dancing like i've never danced before on
the ceiling in fact like the old lionel
rich what's up
um well i've got a really tough question
for you today
bring it
probably the toughest you've ever had
my husband and i are trying to navigate
santa claus
and parenting are
our kids
coming from two different uh tutors in
christian backgrounds okay
so
what what is so you and your husband
disagree on
the
what role santa claus is going to play
well yeah well i guess
whether we're going to teach our kids
to believe in santa or not god teach
them to believe you said that's so great
um
okay so
i
on the internets posted something about
never lie to your kids like it drives me
crazy never lie to your kids
and the number one question i always get
back is what about santa claus what
about santa claus what about santa claus
and so when i hit send on those things
i'm always thinking about
you know divorce and
you know grief and things like that and
everyone's like what about santa so here
we go let's answer this definitively
once and for all and
on the internets there is no once and
for all it's forever never amen okay so
how old are your kids
uh i've got a two and a half year old
which is who we're thinking of i also
have a nine month old okay
all right so what do you want to do
well before kids i didn't want to um
teach them about santa
why not scrooge
funruner.com.net
i i didn't
i didn't learn i mean i didn't believe
in santa i grew up in a really christian
home that we didn't do halloween either
so basically just just not just no
holidays
no no holidays um is that in the bible
didn't lie to us we knew about him and
you know we like we could
you know we had stockings and my parents
filled them in the morning and we just
pretend you know but it wasn't we never
believed
my husband what faith tradition are you
from
christian
my dad uh was a lutheran pastor
is that in the bible
what nobody living in santa no i mean we
we celebrated holidays but we didn't uh
we weren't about santa and then we
couldn't participate in halloween it was
too much of the devil
very cool okay yeah so
yeah i wouldn't call it cool
did your do your did you dress your kids
up for halloween this year
we did yes dude you're breaking down the
barriers man
your dad has lost control of his
daughter
yeah it's going off the rails in twin
cities i love it okay
so
husband is he all in
yes okay
and i i think it's super magical but
then yeah like the line when your two
and a half year old looks into your eyes
and asks you if wookies are real um
and you're just like
no no they're not but he believes in it
so much because he heard it in a book
once
it's hard to then be like no i'm gonna
teach him about santa and then
shatter his dreams at four or five years
old
it's so great
the transference of trauma from one
childhood to another is so great
watch it in action so good
okay so here is my thoughts on santa
claus
i believe that we have in an effort this
is all derivative from the enlightenment
we're at the back end of the
enlightenment i believe
we
thought we could break everything down
into its smallest parts smallest pieces
we bought into a lie that everything's a
machine so if we took the body apart
together and all the way down to the
smallest cell we could figure it out
and what we lost in that was
myth
we lost common stories that we told
ourselves things that bonded us together
and what we're finding out is uh if i
was just listening to andrew huberman
yesterday he's one of the smartest men
on the planet i love him he's at
stanford talking about how people heard
the same story
and they were they listened to the story
this is a study i think it's in cell mag
like the top top top scientific academic
journals
different people listen to the same
story in different places at different
times and their heartbeats lined up
here's what i'm getting at we are bonded
through connection not through are the
smallest pieces of us okay
so here's why that's important
i believe we have in an effort to
quantify everything to solidify
everything one of my favorite poets um
she says
um
damn the scientists for turning stars
into balls of burning gas
right we used to look up in the sky and
see these magical twinkling lights and
now they're just
sulfur and hydrogen and whatever we've
ruined them okay in an effort to take
them apart so what does that have to do
with santa claus
i'm a big believer in not stealing
stories and common experiences and
things that are a part of us
from our kids because the world's gonna
do that from them they're gonna take
everything from them
they're gonna they're gonna the world's
gonna ruin the greatest things about
being a human laughter and sex and joy
and family and relationships it's all
gonna end up a mess
and so man if you can create a magical
five six years with your kid
i say live every second of it
and create the
magic create the universe all that stuff
let your kids enjoy that with their
friends and their kids and then what
they'll do is over time they begin to
figure it out like wow santa claus is
like in four different places in that
mall that was weird they'll start to
figure it out and it's how they begin to
peel back the world but they do it at
their own pace and at their own speed
and then there will come a moment when
your kid looks at you and says mom
listen
i don't believe in this anymore or
mom i got to ask you is this real or as
my son did
he conflated god and santa in a really
really deflating way
and so here's what i did i think i don't
remember how old he was but it's one of
my favorite moments i've had with him
i
it's just like out of a
taste of like a taster's choice
commercial like an old beer commercial
or something i
he said something along the lines of
i'm gonna ask god for this and if god
doesn't come through i'm gonna ask for
sand i'm gonna have santa something like
that i mean it was just a total mess
so my wife looked at me and we have the
rule in our house that whoever gets
asked the question has to answer it
so i said hank come outside with me
and i took him out this is so cheesy i
know i took him out in the back of my
pickup truck and we climbed up in the
back of the pickup truck and i said son
sometimes this is where we have hard
conversations this is where grown-ups
have hard conversations in the back of
the truck so we're gonna have one and i
just gotta level with you
and it was one of the most magical
conversations ever and it was me saying
hey i wanted you to enjoy this i wanted
you to love this experience there was
something magical about waking up in the
morning and did we hear the rooftop all
that stuff
and
i got a level with you it was me and
your mom and i walked him through it and
then it was so great as we were getting
down he felt so big and so like it was a
great moment between us he got while i
had told him the stories and why we
wanted him to enjoy that experience how
fun it was
and then as we were leaving he goes dad
one more thing and i was like yeah and
he goes
easter bunny no and i said
no son and he's like all right so we we
had the thing right and so here's the
thing it's a common myth it's a part of
us and we have just sucked that we've
made it truth or fiction kids are much
more fluid than that
and their experience of truth evolves it
moves in their participation it's the
the same thing is i'm not going to let
him go see a movie
because i don't want him to ever think
that star wars is real i'm not gonna let
him go to the theater because i don't
want him to believe in romeo and juliet
no man don't do that don't take that
from your kid is that fair
yeah that's fair i do think elf on the
shelf is from satan i think i i agree
elf on the shelf is evil it's a way to
if you're listening to this burn your
elf on the shelf burn him do you all use
elf on the shelf
we didn't
james you elf on the shelfer
uh not in the traditional way we kind of
like
uh do a
it's it's a long story
we kind of like do the elf on the shelf
but we don't make it like he's watching
you you better behave because that's
kind of creepy more that he's staring
you down and judging you
no just kind of like hey you can teach
him about the christmas story or her
about the christmas story and you know
help her understand what it's all about
stuff like that and yeah we totally use
it as a threat
yeah we're like don't make us go tell
our elves was alphys
and we had like you know elvis is
watching so yeah james is a better
person
this emily is why kelly's kids are
probably in counseling
they are
right that's right so elf on the shelf
from satan directly from satan if you
don't want your kids to do something
just tell them yourself you don't have
to like pawn it off on some toy on top
of the ceiling but
um yeah dude i'm all in on it let him be
a part of it let him own it
and then watching my son
and like
teach the story to my daughter and let
her be a part of it it's just fun man
it's just we just gotta bring some fun
and joy back into our lives is that fair
yeah that's totally fair i don't think
it's i i don't think it's lying to kids
any more than taking them to the movies
or taking them to theater anything like
that is there will come a moment when
they start to say well what about the
story of if you have a faith tradition
you know if you're a muslim if you're a
christian
oh what about how does this work that's
a whole other conversation by the way
their understanding of god is going to
shift and morph over the course of their
life too like yours has right has yours
shifted and morphed
yeah yeah see so that's part of their
journey and part of their adventure
just don't don't don't put so much
weight on this thing i'm all in on santa
so are you gonna do santa or not are you
gonna steal from your child i'm
skeptically kidding
no i think i think we'll do it yeah we i
mean
we were halfway in the door anyways but
then i just got cold feet i was like
cold feet do you when you listen to your
husband's stories do you feel like you
missed out
um
you feel like he's an idiot like your
parents sucked what lame losers no i i
don't think either i think i
i
i felt like i knew something
that no one else like no other kid did
because they all still believed as a
child so i i was fine with it i thought
oh
it was like it was like a power move for
you it was like a flex you're like
my peasant little friends and they're
dumb they're dumb myths
good job but i didn't paddle at all i i
kept it a secret until my friends
figured it out i had a friend named
brian and i told him it's one of the
worst his mom told me to leave his house
and she should have it was one of my
wait did you not grow up believing in
santa oh no i just had an older sister
who loved ruining every every
oh you believe that idiot so she loved
that she was awesome um but i ruined it
for a friend but nope i'm all in that's
how i do to my house i'm all in do your
kids believe in santa
yes yes but again we're
we don't like um
make it all about santa it's kind of
like and we don't also we don't like
create this
like well here's how he comes down the
chimney we're kind of like i don't know
what do you think like kind of keep it
mysterious so we're not like just
kelly you're all in yet again james is a
better parent mine did and
i have a special needs
daughter who's 18 but only about five
developmentally so she still believes
she's all in yeah
it's magical right yeah and even my son
now he
he plays into it now we all do it now
because she still believes yeah it's so
great the one thing that we don't have a
fireplace in my house emily and
we don't
so josephine was asking and i was a
little bit creeped out at myself
explaining how he can just get in the
front door like i thought that's
probably i mean that's going to come
back in some counseling sessions someday
and then there was this guy that just
came in the front door and so anyway i
get that it's probably not the best
story to tell but it is where we're at
right now it's cool i might get some
deer hooves and and hit him on the
ceiling this this year we'll see all
right that's my thought on santa so as
we wrap up today's show or a couple days
out i want to wish everybody a merry
christmas
and here's the song that could have been
written
for a serial killer
or a stalker or
santa claus
and i'll wait till we get to the uh the
uh chorus to read the title the song
goes like this
you better watch out
you better not cry
you better not pout and i'm telling you
why
he's coming to town gather round and
he's making a list and he's checking it
twice his most abusive song he's going
to find out who's naughty or nice he's
coming to town and he sees you and
you're sleeping and he knows when you're
awake and he knows if you've been bad or
good you better be good for goodness
sake you better watch out you better not
cry you better not pout and i'm telling
you why he's coming to town rudy toot
and rummy tum tums
little tin horns little tin drums
the kids and girls in boy land that
sounds weird we have a jubilee
they're gonna build a toyland town all
around the christmas this thing is just
getting off the rails this is this song
not great
but he is kids
santa claus is coming to town not here
on the dr john dolone show
[Music]
you